from screen junkie studios in the Heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host Andy
signor greetings screen junkies welcome
to an amazing episode this one has been
asked for for so many for so long uh our
friends over a collider of so many
Talent people over there and we thought
what better way to bring them on this
show than to make them all come and to
all fight and they're here today look
over at that couch
yay oh man we got Christian we got John
schnip we got Dennis Ken napso Perry
neov Mark Riley Wendy Lee Josh muga
thank you all for coming guys thank you
so yes a few of you guys have been
meeing on the show for the longest time
and we'll get you back officially but
you're here now for the first time some
of you are I've done this show before uh
but this is going to be a different
format if you're not familiar with our
last fighter standing format the way
this is going to work today is I will be
drawing the names out of a hat this is
completely at random it's not a Twitter
poll we thought that wasn't fair this is
completely random I'm going to pick
three of you to come up here and fight
for the first round but to change
today's episode and make it a little bit
more exciting the the first player I
pick in this first round will also get
to pick which question we do now these
people know the six round possibilities
but now there's actually an advantage
you guys can play because the first
person I pick will get to pick the
question and then the winner of every
round after that will get to choose what
the next round question is and we'll be
able to answer first which is a huge
Advantage so you guys everybody
understand how playing this does this
make sense yes you're at a little bit of
a disadvantage if you have to go first
cuz that means you're going to have to
stand here through the whole fight to
make it but it can happen Dan Merl who's
on the couch he made it to the very end
on our first last fighter standing but
then you lost to Alicia right did I did
but I I redeemed myself because I she
cashed in and I was able to to win the
day but yes it's not fun and it's it is
fun but it's not easy anys do you have
any tips for the players uh well yeah I
mean you know if you're up there for a
while just remember as long as you're in
the top two with the beginning you stay
but with the added advantage that adds a
new wrinkle but yeah it's uh usually
you're trying to win every point but
sometimes I don't want to give you
strategy tips but sometimes if there's
one player that shows a weakness it's in
two players interests to uh stay in the
game so team up and destroy you just you
got to play it strategically well I'm
excited for it shall we do
this this is going to be intense all
right first player up I'm not looking
I'm Just sh shuffling here we go first
player is and you will choose the round
that's only advantage since you got
picked first you'll choose the
question Perry Nar off oh Perry ohry I'm
so sorry but hey you at least get the
advantage of this you will choose the
first question she's got bangs
Perry so Perry welcome to the show come
on up here next up taking on Perry will
be oh I can't JT this is going to be fun
the graphic challenge I'm I'm excited
made JT do a lot of complicated Graphics
today with random order next
up Josh
muga taking on Perry and Josh and our
first round will be our last one for the
first
round Mark
[Applause]
[Music]
Riley wow you three should wa play the
lottery no you shouldn't is that
odds of getting picked well it's all the
same for all right so the rest people on
the couch will potentially advance to
round two so consider that a break
welcome guys so let's uh let's do this
first up Perry Neo thank you for being
here oh thank you for having me I'm
excited to finally get to do movie
fights this is going to be so much fun
uh hopefully you get some horror stuff
right that would be nice yeah okay good
uh next up Josh muga what's up Andy you
crushed TV fights been here a couple
times in TV fight a lot of fun I'm I'm
excited for this because a lot of people
don't know actually watch movies as well
yeah we'll find out if that's
true lastly Mark Riley so happy to have
you back you played this game a couple
times good to be back Andy so you have a
little bit of an advantage here I I no
not with these guys these guys are great
I mean we we do this for a living let's
do this I'm having fun all right we're
going to do it first round now Perry
what is the round you're what question
would you like do we have the graphic of
our question oh yeah come on Perry I
know I'm going here we go which question
would you like to tackle first I want
question number three pitch Adam Sandler
next terrible Netflix movie all right
okay I love it all right I have to this
is really complicated I adjust my
schedule to see here we go Netflix Andy
question for you before we start is this
Andy is this Andy Samberg is this Adam
Sandler is this do you want the movie to
sound horrible or do you want it to be
good uh it needs to be the most Adam
Sandler okay got it got it is that is
that clear the most Adam s sh all right
now before we do round one I do need to
say a word from today's
sponsor Adam Sandler we good this
episode I'm so happy is brought to you
by screen junkies mugs that's right hi
have you ever struggled with drinking
out of a tap or from a gallon of milk
and wish there was a smaller receptacle
you could pour your drink into for
easier consumption well that's right the
screen junkies mug solves that problem
you can drink hot drinks cold drinks
bubbly drinks or even Mike's Hard
Lemonade you can get your handle on your
beverage with the screen junkies mug get
it today for the low cost of $10 move
quickly cuz inventory is limited go to
screen junkies.co merch or the click in
the description below screen junkies
mugs look how much fun they're having I
I think we can agree drink like a screen
junkie but don't drink like kidnap
sock drink like
K you could sip like KP sock there you
go screen this is that is a for real
commercial act fast cuz we don't have
that many in there but we'll order more
if you guys really want
telland mugs the last couple years
honestly how good does this feel
unbelievable ergonomic ergonomic handle
with the easy pull it looks like it's
dirty but that's actually a style it's
called like something it's a 101 dalmati
style yes 100 before this he T striker
in Airplane he had a drinking problem
all right here we go round one come on
Perry Oh I have to go first I want to
fight you you want to fight let him
fight stop this F I'll K you I can do
this all
day all right round one here we go Perry
you get to start us off and you get to
pitch right the best Adam Sandler
Netflix film for his new four picture
deal that they just signed from pitching
Adam Sandler's next terrible Netflix
movie and I'm pretty sure I have the
perfect combination I want an Adam
Sandler character Team Up movie Avengers
Style I want to kick off the Adam
Sandler cinematic Netflix universe W and
have like Jack and Jill Billy Madison
Bobby B all the most annoying characters
you could possibly think of team up and
I'm going to make it a little more
Terrible by making it a liveaction
animated movie so all the Adam Sandler
characters come together and they got to
fight an animated Alien Invasion where
the aliens only talk minion style if it
doesn't get much much more terrible than
that I'm pretty sure I just locked this
so wait just so I'm clear all of the
Sandler characters are coming back in
liveaction form fighting cartoon aliens
that sound like minions and Adam Sandler
is going to play every single one so
it's going to be the movie starring Adam
Sandler and Adam Sandler and Adam
Sandler and Adam Sandler I think that's
that's an instant win in other Sandler
character friends be in this character
friends like his his his actor friends
his actor friends oh my yes you can I
mean you could put them all in there now
I got to
think okay well you can keep tell us
that's going to happen but all right I
got enough for your first we'll come
back for Josh you're up next okay
everybody is really looking for that
that Adam Sandler reboot that we've all
been dreaming of and I'm going to do
Happy Gilmore the senior tour now here's
what happened after his legendary
performance at the Tour Championship
when he took down Shooter McGavin his
career has gone to the skids he hasn't
won a major since his uh career with
Subway went through he's tried to he not
only did he come back and try to play
hockey again but he jump kicked a man on
the ice instead of stabbing him he was
the first play to actually try and jump
kick somebody uh he's now back trying to
make it on the senior tour except he's
had major back surgery and thus can't
run up to the ball and has to swing the
club normally all the normal characters
are back like Shooter McGavin now on the
senior tour you've got his caddy David
Spade Kevin nean David Spade wasn't in
the original happy G but we're throwing
him in there because he seems to be in
all of them a Rob Schneider perhaps a
Kevin James as as a Kevin Stadler coming
in there maybe a Duffy Waldorf and
obviously going to get a Lee Travino
you're probably going to get a Tiger
Woods cuz he's not doing anything you
know what you need in an Adam Sandler
movie as many cameos as humanly possible
and how do you do that you make Happy
Gilmore the senior tour 75 cameos per
act making it the greatest Adam Sandler
Cameo movie
ever5 per act okay per act yeah all
right Mark try and follow that well I
can Andy because I'm going to tell you
something with Adam Sandler's career
being the way it is it reminds me of a
lot of franchises that come to the end
of the Stop and they need a fresh start
and what do they do they send them to
space Adam Sandler in space with a
little twist because as we saw with
ridiculous 6 he was doing a a little
Riff on the Quinton Tarantino uh movie
uh so we have Adam Sandler kind of
riffing on moon Oblivion Adam Sandler
clone we have a bunch of clones however
they're in a space station nobody knows
who is the original so you have a bunch
of clones running around not knowing
what's going on who's the Clone who's
the real guy are you I don't know I
don't know so they're trying to figure
it out all the while their space station
it's crippled it's going into orbit and
it's going to crash into Earth and these
[__] clones are trying to figure out
how to save the Earth and hilarity
ensues is Sandler playing the Clones of
course he is all of them all of
them yeah all right so we have two
movies here with multiple Sandlers and
one just going back to the well all
right fight it out guys why is yours I
I'll I'll be honest all three of them
are terrible I don't know if that one's
so terrible it's a big Happy Gilmore fan
you're just complimenting me on my on
the senior no I am complimenting here's
the thing I think with both of your
movies what you're getting at here is
that Adam Sandler is really trying to
take over his Eddie Murphy Roots right
he wants to play he wants to go back to
that Jack and Jill the classic that the
Oscar nominated Jack and Jill I know
Christian harof favorite Adam Sandler
movie what what you're missing here is
uh that Adam Sandler can play so he is
so versatile in his roles when it comes
to it he's got southern guy he's got
southern guy and uh of course
everybody's favorite yelling southern
guy so what you what you what you're
missing with just cloning him and having
him fight space aliens is a character
study you could go back to a toll booth
Willie could you put him in there could
you put you know uh the goat you could
you put him in those movies and the way
you're panting it out I don't think you
can do that you're going off the
argument that this is the terrible Adam
Sandler you're pulling in characters
that are beloved by the fans Happy
Gilmore even Perry I love your Avengers
team up you're bringing back some
favorites Billy Madison we're talking
the Adam Sandler awful Netflix he's not
he's not going back and doing Happy
Gilmore we're talking clones doing this
thing since like Jack and Jill like
these movies where he's running around
like a bumbling idiot I would love to I
would actually turn on an Adam s Movie
that that was a sequel to Happy Gilmore
because that's one of my favorite Adam
Sandler movies I would look at the
Avengers and go oh my God Billy Madison
is back I'm going to check that out this
is a movie clone Adam Sandler I would
not turn it on that's a horrible
horrible Netflix Adam Sandler movie Adam
Sandler Cinematic Universe even worse
cuz that's a great idea adding more
characters from his other movies and if
it's a Cinematic Universe you could pull
anybody well Little Nikki is already an
Avenger in this idea I want Peter
Dinklage from from the pixel movie I
want Taylor lner from grown-ups because
who's a bigger scene stealer in
grown-ups than Taylor lner candy Samberg
and that's my Bo Wanita from Billy
Madison she's amazing snack packs yep s
you got to have the snack packs and then
you add Kevin James but he plays at the
same time the same role he's played in
all of his different Adam s mov here's
the you guys are missing out on what
makes a lot of these movies terrible a
John mackenro Cameo you're forgetting
him you could put wait but are you
saying happy goor is terrible because
I'm going like we have
some Gilmore on the senior tour with a
back surgery problem to I I thought we
were
going no we're going at the argument
this is a ter clarify the question is
the question is pitch n Netflix's next
terrible Adam Sandler movie I did add to
the caveat of it needs to be a Sandler
movie uh all three of you do fall into
that but yes uh it does still need to be
terrible and still Sandler esque so
we'll go around for final thoughts I'll
final thoughts yours is more terrible
more terrible is we are revisiting a old
cliched Adam Sandler thing what he did
with Jack and Jill which is he's just
playing himself but with like different
kind of costumes maybe longer hair
that's why you get these clones they all
have a little bit of a different
personality but come on it's Adam
Sandler he's going to do the same shtick
and then times that by 10 and they don't
know which is the original and which is
the Clone I mean awful Josh you what
here's the thing no nobody wants to
reboot Happy Gilmore it's the perfect
movie everybody always talks about that
as his greatest movie so what are you
going to do you're going to take your
childhood and just step on it by making
Happy Gilmore the senior tour he can't
play golf as well cuz he had back
surgery his his new sponsors aren't
Subway Julie Bowen left him years ago
shoot him a Gavin his back on the senior
tour 75 cameos per movie does that not
sound awful Go Happy Gilmore it's great
Happy Gilmore sequel Happy Gilmore the
more you describe it the more I actually
want this to happen
yeah son of a [__] I'm better than Adam
s God damn it finals yeah any any living
breathing human being out there can only
handle so much Adam Sandler especially
so much recent Adam Sandler and when you
put a whole bunch of Adam Sandler
characters into one movie it is bound to
be terrible especially when you add the
liveaction animation part because who's
seen very many good ones of those so
picture lots of Adam Sandlers fighting
little minions and your head's going to
explode all right wow well you guys did
a great job pitching terrible movies Dan
how what are they saying online well if
my calculations are correct 75 cameos
per act would equal 225 cameos yes
you're welcome it's the most in movie
history one quick clean up with Taylor
lner uh I I I know that these are
cinematic Classics so I'm sure this was
honest mistake was in Grown-Ups 2 not
the first grownups way to go Perry also
ridiculous six right seven whatever also
in Valentine's Day but that's not a
people people uh on Twitter generally
just uh reviling whatever Universe it is
that these movies would exist in Lang
Liam Neely says oh wow at Pim just
pitched the
apocalypse Sarah Wendling says I'm
enjoying how far in these Fighters are
leaning to the Sandler question they are
all sadly believable movies Duke devil
95 wow and people thought ironfist was
bad these movies would make me drop
Netflix so all rightn so they so all
three have sold our our audience on the
terribleness of their films all right
well now it comes down and there's a
poll oh there is a poll great well let
me so uh you all did a terrible job I
I'll be honest the one that sounds the
most Netflix to me is marks yeah that
one actually sounds like it might get
made it's just really depressing we're
in development right now Andy so I
really can't say more maybe should write
one yeah uh but that no offense I know
you were doing it terrible but that
sounded terrible uh so it came down to
Perry and Josh but yeah Josh the more
you kept talking the better it sounded
in a weird
way so sadly I got to go
in total reversal of Fortune on movie
fights I you my best M but I how's this
for promise I'm bringing you back for
another episode so you can try this I
was very impressed my one round I did it
guys Round of Applause over Josh muga
very good try man these mugs are best if
it had been best Sandler uh you would
have won thanks H but Mark you win the
round because I thought yours was the
closest to being a Netflix movie Perry
you're still in this you're still here
but now it's time to tackle your next
fighter uh Mark you'll be picking the
question though okay uh but here we go
if it's any consolation to Josh Twitter
would like to see or not like to see
Happy Gilmore seniors or 45% voted for
Happy Gilmore 32% the animated Adam
vengers
23% Adam spacer
Oran yeah the
ASU all right here we go next fighter
are you ready to go I'm pulling out the
name
is
[Applause]
Christian
CHR how are you how are you good to see
you hello welcome how are you hi nice to
see you Christian thanks for doing this
I know we're a little at odds CU we're
about to we're about to rematch I I
respect that you're finally getting back
in the can only take so many texts so
long I appreciate it from from everybody
thank you looking forward to that no I'm
it's going to be a lot of fun it's going
to be good we're going to play like
gentleman this time ABS but I'm still
going to be a jerk yes uh but here we go
uh next round up so here's the question
uh you get to pick the question mark
let's see him again these are great mugs
by the way yeah thank I like these mugs
they actually are pretty they're nice
and big too all right Mark you get to
pick the next question great I want
who's the best alltime movie monster
going to pick that oh yeah o I like this
yeah yeah best movie monster I'm going
to represent some cider nightmares here
and go with and you get to go first all
right good because the best movie
monster of all time hands down is the
alien xenom more from the Alien series
and here's why alien is just now getting
started with another movie in Alien
Covenant with Ridley Scott teasing alien
Awakening the sequel and another Trilogy
after that so if you go back to alien
and Aliens they are one of the highest
rated on Rotten Tomatoes right now Alien
aliens is highest at 98% if you go up
against other movies like Pacific Rim
with 70% superade 82% even Gremlins at
85% and the Big Daddy of them all
Godzilla at
74% then you take alien and alien iens
and I know Alien versus Predator it be
smirked the alien name however it made
lots of money alien and versus Predator
high up there on the list of alltime box
office when you compare to other monster
movies the alien is by far one of the
greatest designs by HR Gyer it is
instantly recognizable alien Covenant
the marketing is going back to the
basics showing the alien egg showing the
alien creature with simply saying run
that tells you everything fans are
excited for this next movie I know we
have Kong Skull Island out in theves we
have another Godzilla coming but alien
is this movie franchise we keep getting
him we keep getting them the the the
Rotten Tomato score should tell you with
the alien and Aliens has set the
standard for this movie we're going back
to it with Covenant the box office is
only going to get bigger and bigger with
all these movies coming up next Perry
You're Next I am going to go with the
fly
I liked your pick Riley but I have to
say the fly one of the coolest things
about the fly is that every single major
cinematic Monster icon out there has had
almost everyone has had some sort of
flub it's it's had its AP or something
that tarnishes its reputation the first
fly is incredible Jeff Goblin or Vincent
Price I was I was trying to get the fly
in general but I'm going to go I if I
have to pick between the two I'm which
alien are you going gole fly okay from
okay yes and then which alien are we
going to base this off of from Alien
aliens which one do you want to pick uh
I'm going to go highest rated aliens
okay well going backens going back off
of what you were saying you can still
use your otherwise but I just want to
make sure we're all focused on one movie
the reason that the fly is such an
incredible movie monster is because it's
hands down pretty much one of the only
relatable movie Monsters out there the
fly isn't just scary because of the way
another incredible design by the way
isn't just scary because of the way he
looks and that he's super creepy it's
that a person was completely destroyed
he destroyed himself by his own ambition
and you could see that in the fly in his
performance when he gets super creepy
he's terrifying to look at and his whole
character journey is absolutely
mortifying yet another instance where a
character is so memorable iconic and
successful that they're looking at
making another version I don't know if
you could really top brundlefly the that
the fly movie is pretty impeccable and
God that creeps me out as as an
ambitious person when I think about what
he goes through in that movie and what
he turns out to be it scares you and it
makes you think about yourself sometimes
all right Christian I love both those
choices I think those are really great
choices and I would have been
intimidated if he but you guys didn't
pick the guy the only one with King in
the title and that's King Kong he is the
there's a reason why he's King Kong cuz
he is the monster of all monsters and if
we want to go with the 33 version then
let's go with that one because what we
did with King Kong you talk about
relatable King Kong is very relatable
because he's someone he's basically he
is in his environment and he is is
disrupted by people that should not be
in his home he's defending his home he's
defending against these these C other
monsters by the way and he is plucked
out and put into another environment
when he's on the Empire State Building
and you just feel for him in general for
what he has been through and he s there
everyone remembers it it is the it is
the movie upon movies that you first saw
and you realize it this 1933 with
special effects it you talk the first
time when you see that the clish the way
that they did everything back then the
way that they just put him on stage you
believe that it was real and we're also
talking about fights here if we're going
to go the best movie monster if you put
the three of them in there King Kong's
stepping on both of these things and
just with no problem eating them
stepping them chewing them it's not even
an appetizer it's calamari for him so he
is he is going he is absolutely one of
the best I was worried that one of you
was going to say Godzilla because that
would have been a fight for me Godzilla
versus King Kong because that's the
reason why they're continuously using
King Kong in these big monster movies
The Monster boom started to happen once
again with universal and why is it
happening what do they need to do they
needed to have legendary kind of merge
with universal and um and with Warner
Brothers because they had to see
Godzilla versus who the best of the best
King Kong he's the best monster of all
time all right find it out guys okay
I'll I'll say this I would love to see
the reason I picked aliens is because I
have multiple aliens and I have an alien
queen and if I get to impregnate all of
Earth I can take on King Kong with my
aliens they have numbers my friend they
can take it they can go up that they can
take on Kong that would be a good fight
I want to see that whether they will win
or not I don't know but what I'm doing
is the best monster of all time not and
I'm going to box office I'm going to
Rotten Tomato scores and the two that
you keep uh with the fly and with King
Kong that you keep mentioning is
relatable I don't want my monsters
relatable I want them scary and at the
same point what I love about my aliens
is I haven't relied on a reboot or a
remake since it is a continuation of the
series The Fly is now getting remade
again King Kong has been remade again
from the Remake from the Remake from the
remake so I like that this franchise is
still going and still so popular that
we're able to reinvent it go back in
time go forward in time that's what's
great about the alien because what the
alien does is put that fear in you which
I love in my monster movies and then
that puts the focus on great characters
like Ripley like cther Waton who's
coming in for Covenant and Michael fast
Bender these are movies that get great
characters alongside these monsters
relatable is a different type of horror
though Rel relatable is one that gets in
your head and it sticks there and it
makes you think about yourself you think
about the characters whereas when I'm
thinking about King Kong you know stomp
stomp stomp bash stuff up and and then
that's kind of it alien alien freaks me
out quite a bit I I don't think I can
knock that too much just because if I
didn't go with the fly I would have gone
with alien yeah but the thing is with
the fly is that he's defeated pretty
easy here and he's got he's got one
Mission really and that's just with he
it's he doesn't even it's Humanity at
first and then he loses humanity and
that's scary for a second but he's
defeated pretty easily there's no fight
we're also not talking about scary
though we're talking about the best the
best of all time and when you look at
the fly compared to all the other
monsters there unique the fly is good
but if you're going to put him in a top
five of all time if you took 30 people
together and said who's the best of all
time I don't think the fly is even
remotely interested is it a good movie
yeah you're mentioning box office and
stuff too great box office is amazing
you want to talk about box office about
all the people that wanted to come to
watch Kong on in the theater because he
was this spectacle he was this thing and
then don't mess with khong because he is
out of his environment and you think
he's not scary he eats people he eats
people he ate a bunch of people in front
of I don't want to go near if we want to
jump to Skull Island the first thing he
does when he's protecting everything he
starts like it's like yeah he's protect
oh he's a good dude but he just killed
and ate everyone so he is very scary and
you said well I'm not sure if aliens win
I'm sure Kong would win I am sure and
conf because that's what Kong also had
Kong has confidence Kong when he was the
smaller version of Kong still went up
against the biggest of the best with the
Dinosaurs whether it's the 33 or even
the Peter Jackson version he is always
confident he is always ready to protect
and the thing that brought him him down
was that he was protecting whether it's
Fay Ray or n Watson he's always
protecting the girl too is he relatable
yeah he's relatable but he's also he's
scary and he is the king for a reason
it's King Kong he's I'd love to know go
back through as we're wrapping this up
but like why is yours the best movie
monster the question again alltime best
movie monster it's not best franchise I
think what's tell me why who's the best
alltime movie monster I think for King
Kong the the reason why he's the best is
because he set what we know from Monster
movies again that 33 the version when it
came out in the beginning there was you
had to believe that these things could
exist and he and it it start it's like
anything like whether Star Wars is a is
a movie that that set the the Space
Opera and then people started to do it
and even Mark movie with alien that came
from like Star Wars being first a
popular thing King Kong was the first he
was there he was the one he was he is
the ultimate one to be there before even
Godzilla he is the ultimate movie
monster because he set the stage for
everything even today from Pacific Rim
and all those things they all stem from
what Kong is about I can't argue with
that but I can can say that aliens
became a part of this conversation by
being in the all-time monster movie
category you're going to get that in
your top 10 I would even argue you would
get in your top five because of the
iconic Vis that is that alien the minute
you see it that's why Covenant now is
doing the marketing with that poster and
seeing it because people want they know
it right away just like they know King
Kong I can say that as well but they
know this alien right away and we are
not again I think the biggest lasting
impression that the alien have done is
that we're not relying on a remake we
can continue to go and reinvent this
franchise over and over again because
the one thing alien does is scare the
crap out of you every time I think to to
quote our buddy Hal Rudnick uh both the
alien and Kong are iconic iconic so is
brundlefly and why he's one of the best
move monsters in movies of all time is
because it is it's not just an alien
it's not just a creature he is a person
who is transformed and it's mortifying
and that's a movie and that's a
performance and that's creature design
that has set a certain standard that a
lot of try a lot of other movies are
trying to live up to but all in unique
ways you know you bring up uh you bring
up Godzilla and King Kong and you're
comparing the to like oh no if if you
had said the other one then then I would
have been worried and kind of the same
thing with alien at this point too you
really can't have a deep space movie
anymore without being like Oh like how
does it weigh against alien whereas the
fly will always just be the fly there's
so little that can stack up with that
well just a Kong and Godzilla are always
part of the conversation in Monster
movies and that's why when you say when
you put them together the first thing
you think that's why I was pretty
shocked when that wasn't the first one
uh that was announced these are your
final thoughts go ahead yeah because
when you think of the greatest monster
movies there are ones that are coming up
there and like you said Perry I think
that the fly is is a fantastic monster I
think it's great it's just not in the
upper Eon if I had a Hall of Fame Mount
Rushmore Kong's there first and
Godzilla's right next to him I say that
alien is right up there with it fly I
love because of the character because of
the the legacy of this movie especially
the Jeff Gina Davis movie but that is
more of a a very small point of the
genre like genre fans love that movie
but if you go to the audience you're
going to say Godzilla you're going to
say Kong you're going to say aliens and
that's where I'm standing with aliens
I'm definitely sticking with the Flies
so maybe if you pulled 10 people every
single one of them wouldn't put the fly
in the top 10 but that's not what the
question is it's it's what is the best
monster and when you're talking about
character development and how he fits
into the actual movie that he's in
Unforgettable all right good
fight bam all right Dan any clean up
well people online of course the people
watching at home have so many monsters
that I've seen the general consensus a
lot of people saying the shark from Jaws
uh uh but the one that many many I saw
the most was the thing from uh
Carpenter's movie the thing um um Riley
using some selective Rotten Tomato in
for his
alen just the ones that count yeah there
were some other Alien movies that
perhaps did not do as well yeah no I
mention it the Alien versus Predator I
mentioned is not being great or alien
resurrection sure Dan alien vers
Predator to or the only threeyear all
rotten but Prometheus is
fresh on Rotten Tomatoes uh yeah but but
King Kong at 98% in the flight 91% no
slouches in the Rotten Tomato
departments either um but factually you
know pretty pretty clean round a lot of
people just I think there's so many
opportunities to to answer that a lot of
people just have their own favorites
okay this one's tough for me uh yeah so
summing it up I think you know there
were two more iconic ones as you said
that sort of then became the lot of the
talk but the question was the best movie
monster and I think one of you got too
hung up on the franchise and didn't
focus on the specific monster and Perry
I thought you actually did a really
break great breakdown breaking down why
that's so terrifying that he's a person
that when you said it it just it all
clicked with me of why that's great and
then Christian you really gave me a lot
about the history and his the feelings
and the relatability but Mark I think
you got to hung up on box office
franchise numbers things and yes if
we're if we're arguing what's the most
popular a monster you might have won but
I didn't hear enough specifics as to why
the Queen the specific Queen and her
what she does and why the eggs like I
just didn't get any specifics to the
monster so I got to give Mark the
couch a very good fight I disagree with
that
thank you Andy I I'm sure the internet
will as well but Perry and Christian
you're still in this the winner of this
round is tough I'm going to give it to
Perry ni I think Perry did a really
strong argument as to why he was a
stronger monster and then uh and I think
she was up against the ropes a little
bit so I'm going to give you the edge on
that so Christian you're still here uh
but Mark great round uh thank you for
doing that moving on to round three what
oh what did the poll say Dan I'm sure I
I'm sure it was not the poll voted 6 4%
for the xenomorph from Aliens 29% for
the original King Kong only 7%
supporting the fly but thanks to the 7%
as we remind it's about the arguments
it's not about the choice so there you
go all right here we go next up Wendy
Le come on down you're the next
contestant on
movie I didn't know I was going to get
my own mug yeah we got we got so many
mugs don't forget mugs I forget the can
I keep it uh I don't know how many I
don't think we have that many mugs I'm
I'm a drink from it at least you can
order one though for $10 I
will uh I'm sure we can get you if you
win it's 15 uh yeah uh all right you get
to pick the question Perry since you won
let's see the questions again pretty
sure I know what I'm going with again
this time and I'm going to take number
four nice oh our our title bout very
excited about that one who should be
Josh weeden's Jos we's Batgirl now this
was a surprise story out of nowhere did
not see this coming I'm excited it could
be interesting who knows DC has a lot of
things in the hopper so where does this
live with everything else a lot of
questions that we can answer but for
this fight who do we want to see in Jos
weeden's Batgirl Perry you get to go
first oh I'm so excited about my answer
because I'm such a big fan of this
actress it's Ana Taylor joy and if you
haven't seen her movies you're missing
out it is a shock to me that she is not
already the next big thing she first
broke out in the witch where she almost
carries that movie it's a great Ensemble
but that movie is Scary for the most
part because of her reaction and what
she's going through in that movie then
you also have Morgan which might have
not been the greatest movie overall but
damn does she work that title character
and right there is the perfect example
of her physically being able to embody
this role and then most recently you
have split a huge box office hit that
now makes my fan casting actually
possible people are starting to know her
name she's a really talented actress and
when you pair a rising star like her
with an accomplished director like Jos
Weeden I think you get have the perfect
pairing here Christian you're up next
yeah for me I think that Barbara Gordon
needs to have a little bit of of a
personality you know when she's not in
the suit and she's not as she's not
really going to be uh as dark as say
Batman is that's never been the
character of Batgirl and I think someone
that can be able to kick ass and also
have that later side is Lily James I
think Lily James would be a great choice
for Batgirl obviously if you didn't see
her in Cinderella she's got a she's got
a lighter side there to where she can
hit the emotional side of things but if
you want to see her kick ass you might
not like the movie but Pride and
Prejudice with zombies she was in and
she made it believable she made it I I
when she was kicking ass I was like okay
great I could see her being in this kind
of movie and making it realistic I can
see her fighting crime I can see her
doing these things and she kind of fits
the role and kind of looks like um Bara
Gordon for me you give maybe give her
some red hair here and there but uh
however you want to color her hair but I
think that she is going to she's an
actress she's up and com she's likable
and I think that she is a perfect fit
for for Barbara Gordon Wendy my pick for
Jos Sweden's bgirl is Haley Steinfeld I
loved her in edge of 17 she is a little
bit newer on the scene see Pitch Perfect
um and now in edge of 17 and like
Christian said I think she can give
Barbara Gordon that spice of personality
when she's not in the suit also I think
she's super adaptable she's young she
seems athletic I think she can totally
kick butt as Batgirl and I just don't
think Hollywood has had enough of her
yet she's this up and coming to me and I
think she's Uber talented and I would
love to see her as a redhead wow if this
was like the the short list that it's a
great list was breaking tomorrow
absolutely thrilled um even though I
love both both of these choices I would
still pick Anya over them you know haly
steinfeld's great and clearly she gave a
fantastic performance in edge of 17 just
you know based on everything I've seen
her and maybe other than True Grit she's
kind of fallen into that you know the
quirky junoesque type roles and I'm
wondering if something like that would
would B lead into here cuz I don't think
that would really suit the movie too
well and then with Lily James the only
apprehension I have about that is I love
Pride and Prejudice in Zombies the the
book and I was really looking forward to
that adaptation I just don't think she's
really had the chance to to shine in a
fully successful movie where I think Ana
would be just the safer bet well this is
my point the whole reason why she would
have a chance to shine is because she's
going to be working with Jos Weeden
because as much as I like an teller I
think that the thing she hasn't shown
she has comedy ch at all and Jos Sweden
loves comedy Jos Sweden loves to show
that he can throw in those onliners but
still have very strong female leads and
all these choices are all strong female
leads but I think Lily James fits the
criteria of what Jos Weeden can do and
that's why I bring up Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies because that is a
if Jos Weeden had been announced to
direct that movie I like well that makes
sense I could see that happening and
that's a perfect fit you could see him
kind of shaping her I like Haley snel
very much I just don't know yet if she
has proven as far as an action side has
gone and how much I I liked edge of 17
very much and even True Grit she can go
dramatic but I want to see what her her
physicality is I don't know yet I assume
it could be good but I don't know Morgan
uh Anya was very good in that movie I
just don't think she has that light the
light tone yet that that needs to be
pulled out of her I haven't seen that
going over what you were saying so it's
a a similar point I think we've seen
such well-rounded and such diverse
performances from her why wouldn't she
be able to take comedy direction from
someone like Jos Weeden and every single
person I've ever seen her in interact
with it's like a really rich
relationship there so that is only going
to help her when when you're talking
about pulling something different out of
her performance in that kind of setting
she's the main girl in ingan
andit main I haven't seen witch well you
both talked about comedy chops and as we
can see from edge of 17 Haley Seinfeld's
got and Pitch Perfect she's got plenty
of it and just going from what we've
seen in the past with Jos Sweden's TV
character like Buffy like um dollhous
and things like that I think she fits
right into that that character and for
me I think and I love Anna Taylor joy
and I love Lily James and I think
they're both athletic as well however I
think the movies that they've been in
say for um pride and prej and zombies
have been a little bit more serious and
I think Haley is just a little bit more
flexible and she's already shown us that
she can be funny she can sing I think
she's got this well I think you need to
blend for sure and then then if I you
know if I had the side whether it was if
I was out and it was haly Steinfeld or
Anya I I'm going hay Steinfeld there
because of the comedy element and like
you said she we you just you're assuming
that she can do comedy if comedy was
that easy everybody would be doing it so
I don't know if she's going to be able
to pull that comedy and to work with Jos
Sweden you have to I'm not talking about
slapstick but there is a what the DC
Cinematic Universe is doing now is
they're taking a shift they're going to
plan B they're doing new things that's
why you're bringing in a guy like Jos
Sweden to do this stuff and he's going
to bring in somebody like a lily James
because she is not super well known but
she wants he he takes chances on people
whether it's Sarah Michelle Geller or
whoever's going people that you have not
seen before put them in these iconic
roles he will make her backgirl she will
shine in that role because Cinderella
was an iconic character already she fit
that role like that like a slipper if
you will but she was she was great in
that role and I think she would become
back girl I'll pull the Reigns on the
comedy a little obviously with Jos
Weeden in the director's chair you would
think that that movie would have some
comedy to it there's just nothing in the
report to say oh he's going to to focus
on the comedy this is a must for this
role so with that in mind I think your
best shot in terms of having a
well-rounded actress that is most likely
to crush this role I think Ana Taylor
Joy has now proven herself three times
over so she's just the safer bet and you
know I love Haley Steinfeld too she's
super funny I'm I'm just not convinced
on the actual action part of the movie
cuz I've never really seen her do that
kind of combat before and ly Lily James
is great I I think she does make every
role her own to a point the only thing
that I could say that possibly would
make Anya a better pick is that a lot of
the movies that she's been in they're
they're period costume dramas so there's
so much going on around her that that
could be elevating her performance
whereas Ana's been in movies that are
almost kind of like the bare minimum
there's a lot of great things and
characters and things happening around
her but those movies just showcase her
versatility as an actress I'm going to
use that final thoughts are you good
anything else you want
Christian final thoughts yeah my final
thoughts is to I think that we we're
talking about three solid actresses
three upand cominging actresses but I
think that you also have got to look at
whether I'm going to hark on the on the
thing of Comedy you say we don't know if
he's going to every movie he's ever done
Jos Sweden has had comedy elements it's
how he writes and you want someone that
can deliver that but you also want
someone who can kick ass she showed that
With Pride and Prejudice but the thing
with Lily James also is that she does
seem to be a little bit more versal I
think I think even the roles that she
has done there has been a switch to
where yeah she's been in Period pieces
but I didn't I she really changed her
role as who she was in Cinderella to who
she was in Pride and Prejudice you felt
the character I didn't see Lily James I
saw her and I'll see Barbara Gordon when
Lily James is doing it Wendy final
thoughts and for me I think Haley has to
Comedy chop down as we can already see
and she is someone who hasn't been as
many movies as Anna Taylor Jorge or as
Lily James so I think she is someone who
can grow with the BG girl as we as we
can see her reprise as barara Gordon and
backrow in other films beyond the
backrow
movie okay this is Stu Dan thoughts uh
well as usual so many names being thrown
out on Twitter uh uh Tim Butner says s
shonin would make a fantastic bad girl
she was great in Hannah Jeff Weiss says
tatana and Miss missani meani TJ Dex
Jane Ley is the best choice for Jos
Sweden's uh Batgirl what she showed in
don't breathe says it all Jessica says
Jenna Malone for badgirl Anthony
Hernandez says I'm GNA go with Shane Ley
Woodley because I want to see her
interact with JK Simmons in a
fatherdaughter relationship we don't
know if JK Simmons will be in this this
movie uh but so many more like a lot of
people very excited and thrown out some
great names for this uh we have the
Twitter poll also which is very close
right now so we'll see how it how it so
uh yeah I think I think Christian you
were my leader I think you just did gave
me the best of both worlds whereas Perry
they knocked you on the comedy which I
think was fair and then Wendy they
knocked her on action which I think is
fair with Haley and I didn't hear much
how to defend that and you were sort of
showcasing her singing which I think
know why I got stuck on like she is a
good singer we were listening to music
on the way
here hey you never know they had Buffy
the musical true they did uh and then
Perry you did you did hit back at least
a good enough back with the uh well we
don't know if it's comedy so I I'm
grasping at straws but because I I think
I heard a little bit more as to why the
comedy could work and the action can't
sadly Wendy I'm going to pull you
out sorry that was fantastic round good
work good debut and please we're gonna
have you back this was fun thank you
leaving this you can hold your mug you
can take your mug take your mug take the
mug take the mug take the mug oh wow all
right but Christian I'm going to give
you the win on that Perry you're still
here though this is
intense what was the what what they say
online D we're in like a three-way tie
on the Twitter poll it's like it's
literally right now 35% to 33% to 32%
and it keeps changing so pretty equal uh
support for all of these choices on
Twitter I
great John one of you is coming up next
let's see who we pick who do you think
I'll wait to see I have a hand who do
you think it is I think it's Ken I think
it's Dennis it isnap
snapnap you really you really screwed
him on that I
know there he is John schnip welcome
back to the show what going on you're no
stranger here that's right all right so
Christian you get to pick the first
topic all right let's do it let's see
the questions again we have three left
all right all right uh what is h
Jackman's best non- Wolverine role let's
do that all right so that means you get
to go first Harry will be second John
you're going to be third it's funny
sorry when I was thinking about this you
look at the stuff that he's done and
he's he's very talented dude obviously
but we we Associated most with Wolverine
you look at the majority he's got like
eight or nine movies whatever it is lot
of Wolverine movies so you look at which
ones is like the best and then I looked
there was one movie I'm like it's hands
down there's there's no competition it's
prisoners um prisoners is a movie that
you talk I mean and being a parent
watching this movie you always watch the
way someone is going to react as a
parent in any situation whether it's a
light-hearted role or if it is something
tragic like this and he hits a he gets
into a place that as an actor there are
not a lot of people that can do that
actors or actresses he makes you feel
for things you understand his
desperation from the start to finish you
can tell how well he works with um with
directors and everything he did and what
directors can get out of him because
he's he's from what you hear also as far
as being an easygoing guy he's able to
connect here and his and his accent
disappears by the way it's just gone
he's just he's really good in everything
but his his that that's his that's his
best role outside of Wolverine for sure
oh my I was sure you were going to pick
what I was going for and I'm going Jean
valan from way Miz it's it's his best
actor nominee I mean it's it's his best
performance on Academy standards and I
mean really he is incredible in that
movie whether you're talking about just
his work as a dramatic actor talking and
connecting with all the other characters
because it's his relationship he is the
he is the focal point of that Ensemble
movie and he carries it so damn well
then you can go and talk about his
singing he is an incredible singer
everything in this movie that he does is
spoton and then on top of that when you
think about all of just like the heart
and emotions and how his dad and
inspired him to take this role and to
take it to the level that he did and how
much weight he lost and then he had to
put it back on I mean really this thing
is one heck of an accomplishment I am so
glad he got that Academy Award
nomination because he deserved it John
you know I was going to go with scoop
I'm oh sorry I was going to go with
scoop and then I thought about swordfish
where he's like doing that like I'm in
I've done it but I'm not going to pick
those those are just too easy um I agree
with lamiz it's a fantastic film I I
love D all the performan my favorite
performance was an hathways out of that
film um but I got to I got to go with uh
the fountain that's the one after
looking all at all of his uh his entire
uh uh work which is you know he's done
so many amazing films and some you know
ones you could skip like Kate and
leapold or like Australia I never saw
that I'm not planning on seeing it I've
been to Australia but that's I'm sure
he's he's amazing in everything so it's
like I mean you know Logan made me you
know get te eyed the last film that Hugh
Jack made me get teed was the fountain
and not only is because he portrays
three completely different characters
within the same movie but it's all about
life and death and it's really this
entire Journey from beginning to end not
just early you know going through time
as these different characters but his
travel the main characters travel
through the beginning and of life and
death with his true love so to me I
think the fountain was not just a much
more personal and emotional film uh from
Darren aronowski but also a more
personal emotional performance from Hugh
Jackman now we all know that he's really
good at doing song and dance and
musicals and things like that but the
guy is really he's like such a multi
teered performer that for myself the
fountain is the one that resonates all
right guys fight it out I mean I think
look the thing is with with your
performance too it's the only time I've
heard him on Hollywood reported where he
said he wish he would have done a couple
things different there were things that
he wish that he would have that he
didn't like that he would have changed
up a lot of his performance as far as
lay Miz goes lay Miz is he's great in
that movie and but like schn pointed out
too we knew that he could do musicals we
knew that he was talented before
prisoners is something that we didn't
know he could go there you're talking
about emotional you're talking about
where you can go and the depth of what
you can go to the fact of having a
missing child and making that believable
he's just acting he didn't he wasn't
acting that guy he was in that movie you
saw him he connected you and when you
have a director like Den Anu instructing
you and he brings out we've seen what
iuv has done with uh DiCaprio and and
the fact that he is now a doing that
with uh not Del what he did with Del
Toro excuse me what he did with Del Toro
and what he and what he's able to pull
out now with Hugh Jackman Hugh Jackman
was able to just get something that we
had never seen him do before and that's
why I think prisoners is hands down I
don't know if it's necessarily about
something that we haven't seen them do
before and and even if I guess you take
that approach like yes we know he sang
but we've never seen a performance this
gritty I think from him whereis is
pretty gritt Australia guys that's
really
it's not it's not that badman's pretty
good in it but also just when you think
about I I mean I'll keep going back to
the Academy Award because that pretty
much validates why this is the best
performance but then you could also look
at just the production and the shoot of
lay Miz and the situation he's in you're
talking about Den vuv bringing something
out of him and yeah I'm sure I'm sure
that happened I didn't read any
interviews on him but I imagine that'd
be the case with lame Miz though they
were doing all the live singing on set
it wasn't the greatest conditions he's
walking around with a head and
malnourish the entire time what he was
able to give and how much he's able to
emote and just the epicness of that
character journey I mean you talk you
talk about someone playing one character
it is not easy to take a character from
the point where he starts that movie to
where he ends and make that Journey feel
cohesive and every step of the way he
always reminds you of what he's
experienced in the past and that's why
that character just in general is so
iconic got I got to say liiz I always
think of Russell Crow standing on the
edge of a building like because I'm in a
play AAL I'm standing on the edge of a
building not to me but I
love and I am singing he was fantastic
he should have got that Oscar nomination
let me just say something about Oscar
nominations how useless and meaningless
they are so many people get nominated I
don't care so many people get nominated
and even win Oscars and then years later
you never mention that movie or that
role again it's the people who actually
are in movies that never get mentioned
again those movies that you're watching
late at night like holy [__] the
fountain that's an amazing movie those
are the those are the films that
actually stand the test of time I could
mention Blade Runner I can mention so
many I can mention so many other movies
that have never been nominated but you
mentioning Oscar nominated from L he was
fantastic in liiz but I don't care if he
was nominated or not I think he's just
did a great performance just like
Russell Crow yeah and just like an I
think you got the one to punch there but
I think I think what what I agree withn
there on the F in the first half of that
is that with
there is a lot that comes with with the
first half of that movie and with Anne
Hathaway Russell Crow all the I mean
Eddie redm too the little kid there
there was so much that that people that
were adding because he there were
certain things there were certain times
that it was actually on Hugh Jackman's
soldiers and he and he when he when he
hit he knocked out of the park but it
wasn't all on his shoulders the two both
Gyllenhaal and Hugh Jackman Hugh Jackman
led us into this emotional roller
coaster put the weight of the world on
his shoulders on our shoulders watching
and then leaned on J to help him out and
you also he he enhanced Gyllenhaal's uh
performance it was the two of those guys
but with Jackman leading the charges
where the Ensemble like schn pointed out
and I agree with him great movie I love
the performance and I loved him in that
but let me also add that what you're
talking about you're what you're saying
is it's not just Hugh Jackman's role
it's Jake Gyllenhaal's I'm saying Hugh
Jackman's was the lead Fountain he is
the role it's not like him and
Gyllenhaal team it up the fountain is
all huge AC and he plays characters emal
journey in that movie The Emotional
journey of the of the fountain for
myself at least what I took out of it
for him though his AR his Arc was
dealing with his wife's death from the
beginning of time and dealing with love
love lost through from the from
different perspectives not just him he
plays different characters throughout it
but I found it to be like almost
meditational in one way or another it
doesn't make any difference whether he
was part of an ensemble he was the lead
actor he was a supporting as long as it
was his best performance that kind of
answers the question and it really
speaks to I agree with you it's the it
really speaks to his it really speak to
his ability that he can rise to the
occasion and bring an ensemble together
while also supporting the movie when he
needs to be the leading man
yep I totally agree with what Perry said
about the
fountain I need to know in your final
closing here I'm asking me can you do
one more why is your performance why are
the other two performances not as good
as the one you selected well I think the
performance could chrisal start I think
the performance with the fountain and I
I mean I lean like I mean if again I
think that SCH and I have a similar
argument here to where Hugh Jackman had
to go to in order to bring out this
particular performance and I do think
that the we're both dealing with loss
here for our performances and and I am
kind of pushing aside uh lay Miz because
it's really it even even in and
Hathaway's small role she had more of a
powerful performance people talk about
an hathway in that small more than they
do Hugh Jackman um Hugh Jackman I think
it's an argument between the two of us I
really do because I think that where we
get down to what he does in prison
and I'm going back to that to the the
desperation that you have to see the
fact that he he almost goes from being a
normal dude to killing someone to find
out where where his daughter is what it
is he doesn't care if the person's uh
innocent or not because he knows in the
heart hearts he's got to figure out what
needs to be done to get his daughter
back and you see it you feel it the
power is seeping through whether it's on
screen or on television you feel it
because that is the best performance
he's ever had because you believe him as
this parent the same way that you
certainly do uh at times in the fountain
I just think because aronowski style
overtakes the movie it overtakes the
performance it's the style it's
aronowski is more of the star and it's
more of aronowski shooting that you
remember more than you remember any
performances Perry final thought with
the F the fountain's really the only one
I cannot strictly because just as as a
movie goer that one did not strike me as
much as let's say prisoners or lay Miz
did and with prisoners I don't want to
say it was a bad performance it was a
great performance but when I say what
was his best performance it doesn't
matter if people are talking about Anne
hathway that movie was Hugh Jackman's
best performance it was him taking the
best of himself as an actor the best of
himself as a person and trying to think
about what inspires him and putting it
all on screen every ounce of himself is
in that movie and that's why it's his
best well I was going to mention Eddie
the eagle or maybe even his incredible
role in pan but I'm not going to bring
those up or Real Steel but uh you know
honestly I I I'm not faulting liiz I
mean like none of us are out here saying
you Jackman sucks we're all like hey
look he's been in a couple of shitty
films but overall most of his films are
incredible I stick by the fountain
because I think that is his best
performance not just because it's his
lead performance but it's because you
see him go through different
Transformations I personally don't think
that Darren aros's directing overtook
the film and made it impersonal for me
in fact I remember be feeling very
emotionally drawn into it through from
the beginning all the way to the end
because I connected to the idea of what
loss is and being able to read something
from a book or a poem and take that with
you and those are the the kind of things
that happen through the fountain is all
about transformation and for myself I
think that you Jackman transformed
through that movie all right that was
the hardest one yet uh Dan notes very
difficult I'm looking on the uh on
Twitter there's a winner in the there's
someone leading in the poll uh Josh muga
told me to make sure that you guys did
not Overlook his fantastic word in the
Golden Globe nominated work in Kon
Leopold was the 40 also I will say that
that John schnips perform perance as
Russell Crow and lay Miz is getting a
lot of Twitter love a lot of accolades
from
theow and then lean Summers and many
others on Twitter of course the fourth
one I think unmentioned in this group of
easy ones would be the prestige not
mentioned but many people's professing
their love for his uh uh performance in
that movie but yeah Twitter poll as of
now has a clear winner but we'll see if
that changes while you do the results
Dan what did you think based on those
arguments I need help because I don't
want to I'm grasping at straws a little
bit no this is the toughest one the day
I mean it's they three great
performances um I mean usually I'd pick
a winner if I I mean if I have to pick
somebody
that oh boy was least effective the
least effective right everybody put
together a really good uh argument uh oh
boy yeah this one sucks I here I'll help
you out I'll help you out with this I
think that I think that schnip would be
safe for me but I don't know the the
other way it's too it's too hard for me
it's difficult it's very
hard all right I kind of agree with what
Merl I don't know not to play favorites
but it sounds like d Earl knows what
he's talking
about kind of they did kind of gang up
on you Perry which I was trying not to
let them do I was trying to listen and
not just let because I think they're
threat Christians threatened there
especially I would be threatened by
Academy War nomination so I was
listening but you know I did also they
did had some good points of Just The
Ensemble nature and that an Hathway's
performance was better
um the other two films do sort of have
him deal with more of loss it's a deeper
performance but yours is the Academy
Award nominated performance I get that
doesn't mean anything but it sort of
does uh man this one's really tough I
got to go based on these arguments I'm
just going through the notes sorry to
take so long because I want to do this
right uh
Perry what does that mean I don't know
what those they lose they win what the
hell does that mean uh
shoot uh I
think see for me Christian was safe uhuh
I thought he had some good stuff and
when he said style overtook the
performance of arosi in Fountain I
thought that was a pretty good punch out
yeah I listen it's close I'm not saying
that John was like you know lapped
everybody it's uh I think if F talked to
everyone in the room they had different
opinion he also pointed out that the
Fountain was the one he got the notes so
I'm giving Christian the safe it's down
to to Perry and schnip based on these
points that I'm reaching
out
uh oh man I got a slight Edge to Parry
[Applause]
oh funniest argument I I was really torn
because got break screenies I don't want
to be mad at me but there done it I just
got a little bit more from Perry and uh
I was going to give you an edge for
being
funny but I didn't think that was funny
that's every
day man schneep please come back for f
please come back for a regular fight who
every my favorites John
schnip get your teeth so Christian you
get you won that one so you're still in
this for the first time today Andy uh
the the Twitter pole agrees with you 52%
CH prisoners 35% CH lay Miz and 12% the
fountain that was really tough John to
be honest that was that was brutal with
me all right here we go next
up Dennis Dennis all right Denny
Zen Den
Zen Christian you get to pick all right
let's do it let's see what questions are
left we still have a blind fight in
there you going to save for the end or
you going to ask in honor of the boss
baby what movie character you'd most
want as your boss no you know what cuz I
I I'm I'm I know what I'm I'm going
strategy here because I got that drunk
movie fights Champion waiting in the
background and I know that he would be
dangerous at this category so I'm going
for this one now I I'll go for the which
movie boss okay you are taking the movie
boss the table he had something prepared
that creep I can see him back
there he so bummed he's screaming at me
yeah he was ready for he was he's
screaming at me to go look at this thing
this thing you get
Karma's scream turned into boss he's
screaming at me uh line fight I'm like
yeah nice try uhep all right uh
Christian here it is I'm I'm going to go
a little a little stranger here too I'm
going with the older version of Ferris
buer for my boss um I think Ferris buer
as a boss would be awesome I think that
so wait you're Ferris ber we don't is
there a movie this person's from you're
aren't you saying but you have Pi young
Ferris berer F I'll take young Ferris
fine look we're in we're in the the area
where you you can you can have a
20-year-old boss that's fine um Ferris
Bueller whatever he was 18 he is he is
he he is a dude you know what a fun
place to work and it's not like the
place is going to shut down anytime soon
that dude finds a way to keep getting
deals done it is going to be an
incredible time the company picnic part
is going to be amazing everything is
going to take you a baseball game I mean
Ferris bu in the middle of in the middle
of it he you're going to wind up having
uh you know a song and dance could
happen the amount of people that he
would bring in and then you're just
going to have Cameron sulking in the in
the in the corner but you know that
something is you going you can have
Cameron there doing voices he can
pretend he's Rooney it's going to be
there's going to be so much fun at that
office I could I would love to have
Ferris buer as my boss oh sorry Perry
first then Dennis yes I am going with a
completely out of left field choice and
I'm saying Pat Finley from heavy weighs
I love that character and when I thought
remind me he he is like the heavy set
counselor who who kind of comes together
and he's their he's their favorite
counselor in the Chipmunks and then he
winds he winds up you know leading the
charge in the Apache Relay at the end
and they overtake Tony perkus together
and then he's the one put in charge of
the camp so you clearly know from that
character Journey that he's meant to be
a leader but when I read this question
what I thought was what do I want in a
boss and all I want above all else in a
boss is someone who is crazy passionate
about whatever they're leading and talk
about a guy who cares about his campers
and cares about upholding the the Legacy
the camp hope established and and talk
about having fun I don't want to jump on
the blob all day and have food fights
even though they're probably not allowed
to have food fights anymore but I want
to work at Camp hope kind of and I want
Pat Finley to be my boss okay Dennis all
right I'm going to pick a character who
who played a boss in the movie Big which
was Robert Loa as Mr McMillan for Mr
McMillan's
he's a great boss all he does is he
meets Tom Hanks his character Josh at F
Schwarz he sees that he works with
company he does a little chopsticks with
him on the big piano suddenly he's
promoted to vice president of uh vice
president of toy toy production or
whatever and all all Josh has to do is
play with toys all day and tell him what
what Toys he likes and what he doesn't
do I like a boss like that where I get
to do something I'm passionate about and
have a lot of fun get promoted he's he's
um he he's right behind me he's giving
me a raise I I get to you know get this
nice huge apartment in in New York City
and he he supports me all the way all
right now why are these people terrible
bosses go ahead well I mean I I'd hate
to do this again with Perry though too
but I got I mean I think the Robert hard
time I know I'm sorry this Robert loer
when you hear that like I feel like
Ferris bu and Robert Lo's character
could start a company together as we
that camp closed down the minute the
movie was
over well all all the campers go back
cuz then they want to work for Pat and
they're their lifetime camp that's what
happens know and here's another thing
when you say ferris berer and we
mentioned loia from big they go oh yeah
I remember those guys Andy had to P
looking into his memory go who the hell
is p you want a boss of people know who
it is I don't remember well no I want
the right boss okay right you want to
hear the right boss but you also want to
hear a name of a guy like when you walk
in you're like oh who do you work for
Coke who do you work for Lim blop block
that's who he is he's Lim blop block
because you been told I would work for
Ferris fer I would turn around and go
the other way no you would not come on
how much fun if you work at our office
it's fun for Ferris ber
might I'm the boss over there it might
be fine for a little while but I'm
someone who likes to actually get work
done and and have like a great company
and stuff I could be proud of aan would
make sausages he would be late he would
screw things up he would drive me nuts I
I I'm with Perry like uh I like Ferris
berer he'd be a lot of fun I think
everyone loves Ferris I think it be a
lot of I think it' be a lot of fun to go
to work the problem is if he was the
boss you wouldn't have a job in 6 months
yeah he'd run the he run the company in
the ground he'd make horrible decisions
and everything he makes great decisions
no it'd be a lot of fun 6 months he's
done oh I see I disagree he is a
survivor he's going to make sure that
company that company will always keep
going that is a dude that he screams
billionaire you think he's he's sitting
he's your guy I don't know what that guy
do billionaire I need someone who's
going to keep the company intact and be
super passionate about what they're
doing He he'll be passionate he can run
he can he can run a subdivision of you
know the Kickball Camp
feris since I'm not familiar yet why is
he gonna run that the right way oh he's
gonna run it the right way because okay
so I'm going to spoil the crap out of
heavyweights I'm sorry guys it's okay
it's been out for a long he's a ghost
you should see heavy weights if you
haven't so when the movie starts they
have these super loving wonderful head
their owners of the cam then Tony perkus
comes in and he's douchebag and he's
really
nasty that's Ben Stiller and he like
ruins the camp he basically sucks the
life out of Camp starts Mak making it
exactly what you would think a fat camp
would be miserable workout and he's so
nasty and he's the most terrible guy in
the world and it isn't until Pat and the
campers rise up and Lead it and lead a
charge together that they're able to
take him down so he was the he was like
the head guy in charge of overthrowing
this terrible terrible person who was
ruining what they love and then he was
given control of the camp so there's no
doubt in my mind that if we ever did
like heavy weighs x amount of years
later he'd still be in charge and it'd
be wonderful to be fair also too going
and I'm going to let I'm not going to
let Robert Loa off the hook here too
Dennis is like oh he's such some fun and
great boss that's because Tom Hanks was
a fun dude and he saw he saw it in him
which is great he hired some turds
beforehand I mean he had Ryan Ryan
O'Neal was was running that place into
the ground I mean the stuff that they
were making was terrible his decision
making of who he was hiring for exec was
awful that place was like a funeral home
before Josh got there so he's not making
great choices he got lucky he found one
good dude he found his LeBron James and
he went with it but if you have but
Ferris buer is always making good
choices he knows who to surround himself
he got himself he got himself his friend
Cameron he got his personality of
Cameron he got slown to do certain
things for him I mean even Rooney and
Grace that Grace likes even Grace knew
that how great of a guy he was the kids
all love him because that's why you want
a boss that everyone wants to work for
because that creates productivity that
he's a creative dude Ferris bu would run
an amazing company sign me up Ferris I'm
there using your final thoughts good go
ahead Ferris would probably be like if
he was ever at a successful company he'd
probably be like the number two he'd be
like the class clown of the office just
rah rah and doing stupid stuff anything
Ferris peer does is probably going to
tank eventually and you're you're going
to be the one who's kind of run over for
it like you have a nice car forget your
nice car because that's going out a
window and
and Pat Pat Pat is just the ultimate
safe bet when you're talking about
running a company he is passionate he is
kind he is levelheaded you know you're
in the right boat if you're in any sort
of company and he's at the helm of it
okay so for for me uh yeah uh M Mr
McMillan he did hire some turds right
but but he was able to he was able to
override them when the time came when he
believed in something he believed in
Josh he believed in Tom hanks's
character he was able to override them
even as as bad as they were so he's
still the CEO the company's been around
for a long time it's not going anywhere
stability that that's the key if I want
a boss I want stability I want a a nice
fun job I'm passionate about and lots of
money oh all right that was fun danam
was good yeah just a couple things
Ferris sper is supposedly 18 years old
in Ferris Beer's day off so a young boss
he can legally run a business he can
legally run a business what he did in
one day yeah and uh Josh baskin's job in
big vice president in charge of
production that's the promotion that he
gets where he gets to play with the toys
uh yeah actually that's about it a lot
of I was just I to be honest I was just
listening to a lot of that I wasn't even
reading just curious to see what people
said but uh yeah I I think uh uh there's
a clear favorite on the Twitter poll but
I think it's going to be a very
difficult choice this
round yeah I think for me Dennis
won that the probably the best choice
and then Christian got a little bit on
you but still you defended it fine so it
came down to Ferris sper or Pat Von Lee
Pat Finley you need to watchy uh but
here's where the problem was I didn't
know who Pat vanley was which was
definitely didn't help but I do know who
Ferris Peller is so when they knocked
you down with all the points as to why
he'd be a terrible boss I had to agree
with it so Christian's out Christian's
out Harry's in he' be a terrible boss
he'd run that company in the ground just
like they said man shocker going there
Christian though fantastic job
wow uh 54% of the Twitter audience would
vote for Ferris
berer for Mr McMillan F 16% Pat
Finley Finley vanley not Finley okay
sorry Finley hey he sounds like a nice
guy who at least ran the camp nicely
Ferris buer is just going to break your
car here we go I only have one name left
Mr kidnap come on up
let do
it this ain't
whiskey if you had brought your own
booze I would have been
impressed I got to prove I can do this
sober sometimes Andy it's good to be
back here at the five my favorite thing
is the bathroom stalls with two inches
between the doors so you can talk to the
person waiting for you also like a nice
line so people can see put down the only
belt Dan Merl doesn't own here
oo wow all right well here we go the
last question is a blind fight so it
doesn't really matter what you pick uh
do I have it written down there it is we
wrote it down in here blind fight here
we go
guys what movie should be always playing
in Heaven's largest IMAX
theater what movie should be playing in
Heaven's largest IMAX theater
always
Dennis all right uh I say It's a
Wonderful Life it's a classic Christmas
movie that shows uh a character who who
faces you know doubt he Fel faces guilt
he faces the pressures of supporting his
family his community and everyone else
and and Through The Eyes seeing how his
life would be or others lives would be
without him
he learns the value of his own life and
there's also you know a religious aspect
in there with Clarence the angel and uh
I think that's the movie that they
should be playing Perry your next this
is so easy for me if I go to heaven and
I got to watch a movie in IMAX format
over and over and over for the rest of
the only one you can see for IMX yeah
Jurassic Park I feel like anybody could
have guessed that I was going to say
that if I if I have to watch a movie and
it's wonderful life is great and I I
would Envision that as as an appropriate
Heaven movie but if I have to watch
something over and over I most certainly
don't want to have those messages
repeated in my mind and just see the
value of family and what I'm missing
whereas I could sit back and relax and
watch T-Rex a T-Rex hat per hates
families Carl um I could just watch that
T-Rex rip people apart also just if the
IMAX format thing kind of makes me think
what better movie to put in that format
than Jurassic Park it's one of those
movies where all the effects all the
visuals still hold up you can watch it
over and over it never gets old it's
wonderful Ken uh you know if you're
going to have a movie playing over and
over and over again and and Heaven Andy
you're going to need to focus on one
character and that's Jesus so I'm
choosing the big
Labowski all right all right look I want
to go to heaven I think I'm going to
heaven but I'll tell you what I don't
think there's a lot to do in heaven I
think you're going to walk around a lot
on some you're going to have some puppy
dogs you had in the second grade that
you'll get over that in a couple minutes
you're going to want to be entertained
you're going to want to sit down and
have some fun and that is where you want
to watch one of the best comedies of all
time you can sit there with your friends
your grandfather you haven't seen since
1988 you'll be quoting this movie he
won't know it at first but that's right
and he's going to sit down and then of
course you're going to be able to sit
with Jesus Christ I'm not being
Blasphemous here go with me and you're
going to watch another iteration of
Jesus on the screen nobody [__] with
the Jesus and you're going to be able to
say that to Jesus who's going to laugh
and have a good time you're going to and
and then there's no greater sport to to
pass the time than bowling so you'll
pick up some tips I'm sure they have a
lane in heaven it's like Lucky Strike
but with gold lades it's going to be fun
it's going to be great big Labowski it's
an off-kilter Choice Dennis and Perry
but it is the choice all right guys why
is Big laow Jurassic Park Earth life why
which one should not be there forever in
the IMX you're not going to have any
ladies in your Heaven I'll tell you that
did you think I was anyway you're you're
having I te up for that one so you're
having the sausage part heaven and then
I just I want to have fun when I go to
heaven and I'm not going to have fun
watch but if you're in heaven and I
don't think God and Jesus are going to
proove of all this this killing and
maming of all these characters that
that's because you stopped reading the
Bible after the the Old Testament in the
New Testament God is fun he likes things
he's well come on everyone's on board
isn't the Jesus character in in P laas
isn't he like a pedophile or something
so you think but what is more Christian
than Redemption what is more Christian
than Redemption Dennis yours look I love
It's a Wonderful Life I love it it's
more of an instructional manual when you
get to the lobby and you check you know
you check in at a hotel and it says
here's what you can do that's what it's
a wonderful life is up there in heaven
well in my Jewish Heaven it's meant
to why would you want any other movie
playing on repeat in IMAX again in IMAX
Jurassic Park still best suited for that
format why would you want to watch any
other movie than one of the best movies
of all time it is great that is a great
show he you got stuff on the big screen
but if you are you a fan of Kenny Rogers
the new addition you will be after you
seen that musical sequence on IMAX in
heaven forever just walked in to see
what condition awesome no no no
absolutely yours is
[Music]
great I'm sorry you might not get into
heaven with that song performance of the
movie because it's going to be so big
but I yours is good yours is good but
your heaven and I don't I don't know if
the Jewish faith no it's Eternal it's
Eternal it goes on for forever how many
times can you watch a dinosaur eat Wayne
KN all right quite a bit I can also
watch ax eat it eat the lawyer off the
toilet Den personal hell watching way
night get eaten over and over again uh
again Wonder that's a great sweet choice
that's what you should watch before you
get into heaven so you can convert and
and believe in angels yours is a preh
heaven Choice mine is heaven yours is
yeah yours is all right mine's the IMX
Choice mine's also the repeat over and
over choice how many times do you watch
Jurassic Park I cannot even count and
how many times do you learn new things
about it every time you watch I learn
new things all the time what have you
learned you see little details all the
time and if you have you ever read the
book you know it's a really cool way to
watch Jurassic Park over they don't have
the book in heaven it's only the movie
on IM still I'm happy to watch the movie
in IMX over and
over absolutely so but I'm what I'm
saying is so there's little things you
can pick up about the 600th time you're
watching this you're going to be like oh
the T-Rex is okay what do you what do
you pick up the 6 references do you know
they reference my home town and big
labasi because I don't like I don't want
to watch it Pismo Beach Pismo Beach but
on the third View and you get that on
The 700th View and you pick up something
else like what uh you'd pick up you know
you'd pick up what the the phrase you
know what really uh means to be a
nihilist you'd pick up the fact that Amy
man is a guest star in that movie The
Great singer songwriter wife of Michael
Penn uh former singer till Tuesday she
Lo lost a toe you want a toe I can get
you a toe okay Dennis what are we going
to learn on the 700th viewing of yours
uh I I think like out of out of mine for
my movie it it's more God and Jesus
approved it it's a movie that's not
going to be not going to be thrown out
as soon as they you know as soon as the
first violent act happens in Jurassic
Park they're throwing it out the first
you know curse or swear word that
happens in in um in the big Labowski
that's G it's gone it's not going to get
repeat viewings they're going to show it
once actually they're not even going to
show it once they're going to show it
like uh for like first 5 10 minutes and
then they're going to throw it out you
might be right St Peter might might not
like that but G Jesus has a sense of
humor and he's going to have a good time
and the big Labowski is about Jeffrey
Labowski Labowski who who is a hero he
is a Wanderer he is a man that we he is
a prophet here on Earth here in Los
Angeles Los Angeles in 19912 Era that
you're going to learn a lot from what
are we getting on your 700 viewers I'll
tell you though if if these two movies
are getting thrown out in your Heaven I
I don't want to be there um I mean that
I didn't want to say the blasphemy stuff
here but the the thing you're getting on
the 700 viewing of Jurassic Park is the
same amount of fun and excitement and
inent and attention you got on the first
viewing if you're going to watch
something over and over you need it to
be rewatchable and to be exciting every
single time over and even though you
might get that from the big Labowski
you're not having very many other people
as much as Jurassic Park at least
joining you in your heav and then also
just the I'll come back to the IMAX
thing one final Point not a lot of
people in heav are going to enjoy
Jurassic Park CU not a lot of them
believe in
dinosaurs
all right Dan yeah uh well uh Ken had
one small misstep it's Kenny Rogers and
yeah well factual misstep uh Kenny
Rogers in the first edition not New
Edition than
you uh Twitter had a lot of things to
say but it really is some up by Dan
Brown at Dan Brown VT he said Ken's
answer was too good I need him to be
breathalyzed
uh many the variations thereof people
speculating on Ken's sobriety given the
quality of the the timber of his answer
um I do we do have the Twitter poll
which is uh uh well yeah it's we have a
clear leader in the Twitter poll we'll
see what they say but um yeah not much
facts that I can bring to this with my
Earthly judgment so I leave it to yours
look I got to I got to give Ken the win
on that I think Ken really just had some
mic drops on that so Ken you're safe it
came down between Perry and Dennis
and uh Perry got the other mic dropped
for me which was I don't want to see my
family and what I'm
missing for over forget in heaven it may
be God and Jesus approved but I got to
go Jurassic Park so Dennis Kudos though
you may it very far and thank you for
coming you must come back no thanks for
having me I'll be back so that means Ken
wow you swoop in at the end for the last
and Perry you made it
all how about a round of applause for
these two
first wow all right you guys ready to do
this this is the blind this is the uh
speed round speed round and now we can
activate all of our pass players you
guys will do we have a m we don't have
micone I'm I'm going to come to you guys
to see who uh oh my you can't make the
final call but you're going to help uh
sway if you want on who makes the best
decisions here okay best arguments here
so here we go this is how this works you
have not done this before so Ken has
you're going to have 20 seconds and then
you'll have 10c rebuttal if you both say
the same answer at the same time whoever
said it first and time will begin when
you begin speaking which I'll remind you
as we keep going all right any any
immediate questions I'll best five best
yes five additional points Five Points
you guys don't have any points gotcha
we're back to zero and now you are
collecting the points best of five here
we go question number one what superhero
movie or what superhero should Aaron
sorin adapt into a
film
man it may be an existing
one all right I'll say
Batman I will
say um I will say I will Classics
Superman super Batman versus Superman
again yep but now it's Aaron sorin
writing it Perry your first time begins
when you speaking you'll have 20 seconds
and you'll hear the ding over there when
the time's up well after bvs which I
didn't hate but I didn't love all I
really want is a Batman movie that's
about a character and I can see him
talking and emoting and understand who
he is and who better to write a dialogue
driven Batman movie which would be super
different than any other superhero movie
out there but Aaron sorcin he would do
an incredible job with it and I just
want to see that version CU it's
refreshing that's great you're
absolutely right Aaron s would do take a
new level to Batman and that's what I'm
looking for new levels what does Aaron
sorer do he pulls back the curtain on
the White House he pull pulls back the
curtain on Sports Center pulls back the
curtain on Facebook he takes something
that we we look up and go wow that's
great that's perfect Superman and he's
going to pull back the curtain show the
inner workings you don't need to walk
and talk you need a flying chat and
that's what Aaron sorin's going to give
you in my Superman movie I don't think
Aaron sorin would ever be able to do a
flying chat he'll have Superman walking
down a hall and that's going to be the
worst version of Superman whereas Batman
can scheme and he goes down into the
Batcave and you want to see him think
and um yeah you know Batman's going to
be walking and chatting with himself
Superman's going to have Lois Lan around
he's going to have people that daily
plan you you want to see a clerk Kent
walk and talk that's G to be great all
right that's it time's up good fight
these are the worst
ideas all right here anybody over there
want to chime in thoughts on what you
heard there yeah I wouldn't see either
of these
movies uh as far as opinion on who won
or just based on the arguments yes what
did you guys think I got tight between
the two of those I'd like the counteract
the Perry at the end there because I I
think that the fact of being in the cave
I think uh yeah you would see a more
cerebral
Batman yeah I'd go with with Perry I
think when she mentioned the scheming
part I think Aaron sorin can easily can
do that yeah I gotta go with Perry here
she want me over with her Batman analogy
her Batcave analogy all right I heard
enough John and Mark you'll start the
next one all right I got I agree that's
where I was my head was at too uh the
worst version is Superman walking
through Allway that did stay with me uh
and you CED her up there with the flying
chat because that would be very strange
so Perry you get the first point good
job Perry good job
Perry all right number
two what is the best
movie
featuring Russell Crow
Gladiator oh dear God well i' I've seen
so many competitors do this and they
draw blanks uh I'm going to go with uh a
beautiful mine okay he was in that right
he was you're
safe if only it were Brad
Pit hey it's might not be over yet DN uh
Gladiator and uh Beautiful Mind Perry
you're first Gladiator is a movie that
launched his career it is the ultimate
character Journey it's the ultimate
character epic and he plays that role in
a way that nobody else could have done
it like him like he commands the screen
he was made to play Maximus he's
incredible at it and he's still to this
day even though he has a lot of other
Great Performances he's still known for
gladi year when you think Russell Crow
you think Gladiator he crushed that he
is absolutely still known as Gladiator
because that established him as this big
beefy epic leading man which is why A
Beautiful Mind took him to a different
part of his career took him to a
different kind of performance a little
more quieter a little more deeper a
little more you know crazy at times it
took it was a character study uh
different than what he's known for now I
think he is still compared to the
Gladiator and a lot of people when they
saw Beautiful Mind you do have a quieter
movie in a beautiful mind but the cool
thing about Gladiator is you have a big
action epic and you also have those
quieter character moments you get the
best of both worlds and you get to see
Russell Crow have so much range What a
Beautiful Mind did is it proved that
that Russell Crow could tell a story
with needing not needing you know his
sleeves cut off it was it was something
and and that God damn
it is that it we both have the time
right yeah uh wow that was weird I was
with Ken actually for a little bit but
then he did stay there at the end but
yeah let's go Mark or John in the front
what you guys think uh yeah Ken when you
lost it at the end there I I was with
you for a while but Perry Had A Little
Bit Stronger argument with gladiator
yeah I was going to say uh you guys are
both wrong it's uh LA Confidential
what's up
son but based on those arguments based
on those arguments I would have to go
with a gladiator all right yes I got to
agree you I was with you though and then
you you lost your your train so sadly uh
you get don't at that but fortunately
for per she does he need he needs to get
this I'm on the RO needs to win all of
the remaining points he need to have the
comeback yeah
all
right here we go what animated character
would make the best imaginary friend
W oh godamn
it this is where I've never seen an
animated film in my life come on all
right uh I'm going to go with fival
from americ ta is that one from your
childhood that's one from my childhood
somewhere
oh okay we got Wall-E versus fifel I
loved fifel what's wrong with
f it's a deep cut uh but I love it all
right uh Wall-E whenever you're ready
Perry I absolutely adore Wall-E I love
that character I love Wally's entire
movie and if I have an imaginary friend
that I got with me I don't want to be
talking to that imaginary friend I want
Wally just to roll around with me and
Wally can read people he watches movies
he knows and he has his pet cockroach
Hank so I'd get two friends out of it
because he car them around so now I have
two great pets I never want a friend
that's a person let's be honest Perry
let's let's be really honest s let's
give Fair time here go Fair reset the
time go ahead reset let's be honest
Perry Wall's a bit slow do you want to
spend the rest of the year time with
this met friend who's like trash bug
Perry like that's going to get annoying
after a while fival is loyal and
dedicated you your parents move to
another state he's going to follow you
he's going to sing to this guy some
where or whatever the song is um
he's I don't want a human friend I want
one that's puppy or kitten like and
that's what Wall-E is and he's amazing
and he moves fast you see all that trash
he collects all by himself when all the
other units are gone he's just stacking
it up real quick he can keep up with you
going want a friend that that's going to
teach you some really deep things about
your history of your country he's going
to be there you going to sing songs
Wally's going to pick up trash and get
go spin around in circles trash is fun
like all right at a time fifel is a
mouse f f is a mouse not a person F FAL
FAL they say Russian Polish Russian
anyway Christian you have the mic what
do you think based on the arguments uh I
got can on that one I think he's right I
think that trash can would get annoying
after a while I mean I I just like that
Perry said I don't want human friends so
I'm G to go with Perry on that one hey
I'm going to go with Ken as well he
makes a good point that like Wally it's
going to get annoying after a while
especially you can't communicate with
him at all yeah I agree I guess when you
have Wally as a friend your surrounded
would be extremely clean but that's
about the only benefit front row yeah
Mark or snap yeah go I think Ken I think
Ken nailed it with the Loyalty with FAL
I don't know I think he get a two for
one with Wall-E and his little cockroach
friend so I'm going with Wall-E see that
felt like a cheat it was one so yeah uh
he carries him in his belly yeah he does
he carries around uh I yeah it was a
slight Edge and also just because you
didn't know it was a mouse uh I gave a
slight Edge to Ken so you're still in
this Ken yeah saw that movie Saw the
movie in the
theater me too I remember what is the
song somewhere somewhere out there
somewhere no that's Home Alone Home
Alone right what is the
song there you go now we're going have
to pay the rights we're going to pay for
the rights oh such a sad song uh okay
here we
go best Star Wars character who doesn't
appear in the original trilogy of of
films mace wind do I get a minute to
think no you have like 10
seconds damn it I'm screwed um
bb8 that technically counts yeah yeah BB
versus Mace Wu Ken you're up first this
time cuz you spoke first I have no idea
why I didn't pick Ray but here we go Wu
was the best Jedi of all time and and he
brought something different Sam Jackson
begged to be in the movie and they
rewarded him he chose a purple
lightsaber that establish entire New
Canon but here's what's the best about M
Wu he saw everything coming he predicted
to go back to the phant of Menace I've
seen that movie many times he predicted
everything that would happen he was
right it cost him his life he's an
intriguing deep character he is not the
best Jedi first of all but I have to go
with BBA because one of the biggest
accomplishments of force of the force
awakens is that they introduced a new
Droid that lives up to C3PO and R2-D2
standards he's incredible he's pertinent
to the story he's not just a cute
addition even though he's super cute too
and I'm going to love seeing him in
future movies to come he has the ability
to go the length and
turn I love bb-8 I loved him the first
time around when he was called R2D2 and
I loved in the better version it was
called k2s so droids are always going to
be there you Mace W I'm talking about in
Canon is one of the most important
figures but not as presented in the
movie bb8 is pivotal to force awakens
nothing in awakens Could Happen similar
to R2 and C3PO unless bb8 was
thereo that's how you do it B those
arguments panel what do you guys think
oh that's tight that's TI much tighter I
uh I'm giv a slight very slight Edge to
Ken because I think uh Mace Windu did
bring a lot to the prequels and uh
knowing what to expect with the
prophecy I'm not going to go on my
personal opinion on this one because I'm
for what I heard right now I thought Ken
was going to have it right off the bat
but Perry made some great arguments on
bb8 I happen to think M wind is the
better but I think Perry's arguments
were were much better I think for me it
was very close but because I actually
was more on Perry's side beforehand but
Ken made a stronger argument I go with
Ken that was a really close argument as
well but I got to give the edge to Perry
here I think she made a really good
point about BB's a pivotal uh I don't
know what I'm trying to say but he was
important for the force awakens I got to
go cuz uh bb8 didn't go out like a [__]
so nice Josh did you Tye in Josh yeah
real quick I'm going with bb8 he's
adorable May Windows a
douche Dan did you want to say anything
I I actually would have uh I'll I'll
double b I actually would have gone I
think with with Ken I agree it was a
great back and forth but I think Ken hit
her back a little bit bit more on uh the
drawbacks of BBA than she hit him back
necessarily the drawbacks of M W do so I
would go with Ken actually it's on the
fence and because it's so close I'm
going to give a slight Edge to Ken just
so we can really make this a proper
tiebreaker okay I mean here we go let's
really earn this guys all right ready
yeah this was this is uh this is this is
oh uh okay let's do this
one this is tougher right Ken good luck
yeah it is
best comedy that never had a prequel or
sequel Billy Madison Bri mid wow all
right you guys got those out quick and
those both count M Billy Madison versus
bridesmaid no current prequels or
sequels for those are both safe all
right this is it for all the marbles uh
Billy Madison was first 20 seconds go
ahead when you're ready the greatest
thing about Billy Madison is that there
was nothing like it at the time it
completely coined a new style of comedy
and it launched Adam Sandler's career
for better or worse but Billy Madison is
absolutely hilarious there's very little
like it Beyond Adam Sandler's follow-up
movies and it's heartfelt it's got
actual meanings and messages and it's a
really great movie I that's another one
I can watch over and over for better or
worse worse all right Adam Sandler I'm
not here to make I don't make fun of
that guy he's got a good career but but
bridesmaids brought a to Forefront this
female comedy much needed female comedy
genre the script was Oscar nominated
launched Melissa McCarthy into the
stratosphere for Gilmore Girls she's a
leading lady uh Kristen wigs amazing
some memorable comedy mcarthy for better
or worse but when I'm talking about a
great comedy that also has an epic
Legacy it's Billy Madison I don't think
bridesmaids is going to have the legs
quite like that movie does CU it's still
to this day nothing like it Billy
Madison is that the one is that that
that's not Happy Gilmore it's not the
Wedding Singer what they're all running
together for me now all these years
later I can't quite remember but you
know what I remember bridesmaids I
remember where I
was good how about a round of applause
to both ERS that's how you do it wo all
right let's go around the horn real
quick thoughts based on the
arguments uh I mean I argued Happy
Gilmore up top and based on the
arguments Perry knocking out of the park
Perry number up I'm sorry Ken I've gone
against you every single time so this
time I've got to go with Perry uh I
think yeah I think the argument was just
stronger uh it was close for me they
both made great arguments I slightly
give the edge to Ken he mentioned that
the Oscar nominated script I'm also
going to give the Edge to Ken I love
what this comedy did for female
characters yeah I'm not going to watch
any of these bastard Netflix uh shows
that Adam Sandler's doing
so so so that's no on Billy Madison
okay uh I I think Perry's arguments were
were a little bit stronger I think she
what stuck with me was it def find a new
style of Comedy which which I take is
also launching Adam Sandler as we know
it so you all tied Dan yeah I think that
I think that Perry had it until kenon
his waning second said which one is it
Happy Gilmore what they all run together
and I think that was a really good point
because even me going back I'm like I do
have to sometimes stop and think too uh
so I think that was a really good
Counterpoint so I think Ken snuck in
with a with a killer blow right at the
end there but it's close it's really
close uh thank you for all the thoughts
I'm going to make the final call it's so
close that I think you both should be
feel very good about this you both win
in my book but based on the arguments I
do think the slight Edge for me was
based on a lot of things that were
already repeated was to
Ken Ken you did pull it off I think you
did the Oscar win made the women a film
but then also the you did REM when you
when you pulled that out of which one is
it I was I was edging with her but then
you did take me around it's kind of true
I don't remember now which ones are
which uh Ken napck
wins wow can we get Parry first name out
of the hat all the
way technically Perry really should win
but I got it based on the arguments
Perry W aming Billy Madison Happy
Gilmore and The Wedding Singer of all
movies you guys got to rewatch those
those are the best uh yeah to for for a
lot of
people uh it was really close though but
Round of Applause again Perry wow from
the top you made it to the end that's a
win in my book and I hope you will come
back cuzz you should come do this again
and see where you can uh where you can
go on your own
uh wow that was fantastic Ken great to
have you good to be back that was so fun
you did sober you won an episode you
know she really won because she won more
rounds than you Technically she's about
even all let's go over to everyone thank
on the couch Josh muga thank who's got
the mic yeah me Josh muga will go right
I mean we're all plug in all this
collider and everything but anything
else you guys want to send out Josh muga
Josh muga on Twitter yeah Instagram the
Josh muga show on YouTube collider TV
talk every Monday Christian harof yeah
just check out uh collider video you can
catch the movie trivia shodown and cider
Jedi Council movie talk everything we
have going on over there please check
that out Dennis H you can find me on
Twitter think hero Instagram D.Z and
then Al also collider on YouTube Wendy
Lee uh Monday through Friday on collider
movie talk and on YouTube the movie
couple Channel Twitter Instagram
Snapchat Wendy leany John schnip bu my
goddamn [__] comic book Slayer number
two comes out April
5th
all right Mark Riley follow that up
Riley around on Twitter and Instagram
and also cider nightmares are coming
back once a month stay tuned for that
cider video of course and of course
schmoo main show live every Wednesday 7
o'clock Dan Merl over there at Merl Dan
since I'm there quickly at Merl Dan and
well no yeah come see us at WonderCon on
Saturday Saturday if you're watching
morning
come you guys are there WonderCon owdown
panel on Sunday so if you're there all
weekend long Anaheim Dro by Perry neov
your Twitter
isov yep Twitter and Instagram uh
congratulations really I was rooing I
almost just gave it to you just to give
it to you but I can't do it that way you
really blew me away that was very
impressive can napsack a can napsack
yeah absolutely yeah not only that's we
currently sober is true uh we are at the
Wonder panel we're going to be also at
the Star Wars celebration we got a big
uh trivia battle with Sam witor junk
camp and me so if you're in Orlando for
that check it out oh that's going to be
good we're going to be down there too
let's all party let's do it celebration
stream Jackies collider we're all there
I love it uh that's it we uh I don't
know if we have time do we have we uh
time well yes we'll try really quickly
but thank you for watching we will be
here next week that's March Mania that
was crazy uh and uh thanks for doing it
uh for all you guys for coming and thank
you for watching home we love you have a
great weekend byebye
everybody